[Music]  Courtney Cox and daughter Coco teaming  up for another duet on Instagram this  time for an impressive Hamilton cover  [Music]  yeah between Courtney's piano skills and  Coco's vocals the pair is clearly making  the most of quarantine time the  mother-daughter duo also recently  covered Demi Lovato's anyone  [Music]  what does Coco think of you being like  in the social media world because you  show on Facebook now you got an  Instagram like well I mean yesterday  Coco was sick and I sat down with her I  said coke I'm trying to do this story I  think this would be really funny can you  help me put music to this I downloaded  this app and I'm just trying to edit  this and she's like mom it's just it's  not funny and then and then I just  walked away and she did know how to do  the music so turns out that you know got  some stuff to learn  of course the pair is made their  presence known on Tik Tok so yeah safe  to say Kourtney is killing her social  media game  [Music]